هجوم عبري عنيف على حدود مصر والحوثيون
يجددون هجماتهم اسبانيا تناشد الاتحاد
الاوروبي وبريطانيا تحضر دخول المستوطنين
المتطرفين اليها الاستخبارات الامريكيه
تكشف استخدامات الابي للقنابل الغبيه في
القطاع الحكومه العبريه تضع موعدا لنهايه
الحرب مطالب عبريه بالعوده للهدنه
ونتنياهو يوجه النواب الامريكي يفتح
تحقيقا بشان الرئيس بايدن بعد تراجع في
الفتره الاخيره دول اوروبيه تعلن دعم
اوكرانيا تحذير داخلي لزل نسكي من الدوري
الامريكي وبوتين يضع شرطه للسلام وواشنطن
ترسل جنرالا الى
كياف حرب
غبيه معارك لا تنتهي في حرب لا قواعد فيها
لا خطط فيها وتعتريه العشوائيه هنا ذكرت
شبكه سي ان ان ان تقييما جديدا
للاستخبارات الامريكيه كشف ان ما يقرب من
نصف القنابل جو ارض التي استخدمتها تلبيب
في القطاع كانت قنابل غير موجهه التي تعرف
باسم القنابل الغبيه وعاده ما تكون
القنابل غير الموجهه اقل دقه ويمكن ان
تشكل تهديدا اكبر على المدنيين خاصه في
منطقه مكتظه بالسكان مثل القطاع فيما كشفت
وسائل اعلام عبريه ان الجيش العبر يشن
هجوما غير عاديا على طول الحدود بين مصر
والقطاع من اجل تدمير الانفاق قال موقع
بيهال الاخباري ان هذه الانفاق مخصصه
لتهريب الاسلحه وتحرك قياده الفصائل اليكم
[موسيقى]
المصدر دوليا خرج رئيس الوزراء الاسباني
بيدرو سانشيز ليدعو الاتحاد الاوروبي الى
اتخاذ اجراءات حاسمه لمنع ازهاق ارواح
المدنيين في القطاع من جانبه اعلن وزير
الخارجيه البريطاني ديفيد كاميرون ان
بلاده قررت حضر دخول المستوطنين المتورطين
في العنف ضد المدنيين في الضفه الغربيه في
امريكا اغلق متظاهرون الطريق السريع
بولايه لوس انجلس الامريكيه للمطالبه بوقف
اطلاق النار وانهاء الحرب على القطاع
لننتقل الى اليمن حيث اعلن المتحدث
العسكري باسم الحوثيين يحيى سريع تنفيذ
عمليه عسكريه ضد سفينه حويات ميرسك بلاتر
كانت متوجهه الى الكيان وقد تم استهدافها
بطائره مسيره وكانت الاصابه مباشره حسب
سريع واليكم
المصدر قال المتحدث العسكري باسم جماعه
الحوثي في اليمن يحيى سريع ان جماعته
استهدفت بطائره مسيره سفينه حاويات كانت
متجهه الى اسرائيل واضاف المتحدث العسكري
باسم جماعه الحوثي في بيان ان عمليه
الاستهداف جاءت بعد رفض طاقم السفينه
الاستجابه لنداءات القوات البحريه اليمنيه
بالعوده الى ميدان المعارك اعلنت الفصائل
مقتل ما لا يقل عن عشره من ضباط وجنود
الجيش العبري وذلك بعد استهداف قوه عبريه
راجله بعبوات ناسفه شديده الانفجار بشارع
حسنين في حي الشجاعيه الفصائل اكدت ايضا
استهداف اربع دبابات ميركافا واربع نقلات
جندي صهيونيه بحي الشيخ رضوان بالقطاع
فيما اعلنت الفصائل استهداف غرف القياده
الميدانيه للعبري جنوب القطاع صواريخ رجوم
وقذائف الهاون هذا وافادت القناه 13
العبريه بان وزير الدفاع العبري اف جالانت
ابلغ مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي جيك
سولوفان ان القضاء على الفصائل يحتاج اكثر
من عده اشهر في المقابل قالت صحيفه معاريف
العبريه انه في اعقاب تقرير حول صفقه
تبادل جديده بين تلبيب والفصائل بواسطه
قطريه فان النتنياهو منح حريه العمل
الكامله للرئيس المساد دادي بارنيا بهدف
تحرير لجميع المحتجزين العبريين بالقطاع
واضافت الصحيفه ان القاهره تلقت رسائل من
الحكومه العبريه طلبت فيها فتح مفاوضات
جديده للافراج عن محتجزين عبريين مقابل
اسرى فلسطينيين في صفقه من شانها ايضا ان
تشمل وقف اطلاق نار انساني هنا ننتقل الى
الولايات المتحده حيث صوت مجلس النواب
الامريكي بقياده الجمهوريين بالموافقه على
بدء فتح تحقيق لعزل الرئيس جو
بايدن دعم
اوروبي بعد ان ازداد الياس الاوكراني من
انقطاع الدعم الغربي او تخفيفه بشكل كبير
حدثت انفراجه بسيطه حيث اعلن المستشار
الالماني اولاف تشولز ان الميزانيه
الالمانيه للعام المقبل ستشمل ثانيه
مليارات يورو لتمويل تسليح اوكرانيا وست
مليارات للاجئين الاوكرانيين في المانيا
كما تعهدت الدنمارك والنرويج وفنلندا
والسويد وايسلندا بمواصله تقديم المساعدات
الشامله لاوكرانيا بما فيها الدعم
الاقتصادي والعسكري فيما قال مسؤول
السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزيب بوريل ان العم اوكرانيا يمثل مساله
وجوديه بالنسبه للاتحاد الاوروبي وتسعى
دول الاتحاد لتقديم 50 مليار يورو لكيف
وتعزيز عرض عضويتها في التكتل لكن
بالمقابل فقد قالت صحيفه بوليتيكو ان
الكثير من المسؤولين الاوروبيين يعترفون
في احاديثهم الخاصه بان اوكرانيا لم تعد
تمثل الاولويه الاهم في حياه معظم زعماء
الاتحاد الاوروبي ونقلت الصحيفه عن
مسؤولين اوروبيين كبار انهم يسمون
اوكرانيا بالثقب الاسود الذي يبتلع
الاموال الضخمه وفي اوكرانيا ذكرت صحيفه
واشنطن بوست ان مستشاري زيلينسكي حذروه من
مشاركه معلومات حساسه او سريه مع الرئيس
جو بايدن على خلفيه تسريبات وثائق
البنتاجون هناك اكد المتحدث الرسمي باسم
الكريملن ديمتري بيسكوف ان الوضع في
اوكرانيا يتعقد اكثر فاكثر مشيرا الى ان
السلطات كياف تعرف جيدا كيف يمكنها التوصل
الى تسويه واضاف ان الامريكيين يفهمون
انهم
خدعوا ليصرح مساعد نائب وزير الدفاع
الامريكي السابق ستيفن بريان بان
البنتاغون ارسل الجنرال انطونيو اوجو الى
اوكرانيا لاقناع الرئيس زيلينسكي بتجميد
الصراع مشيرا الى ان الجيش الامريكي لديه
تعليمات لاجبار القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
على التحول الى استراتيجيه فعيه ورئيس
الحكومه الاوكرانيه لتجميد الصراع على
الاقل حتى الربيع المقبل فيما قال الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان السلام سيحل
عندما تحقق بلاده اهدافها في اوكرانيا
مشيرا الى انه يبدو ان المساعدات الاجنبيه
لاوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
تنفذ
مع
[موسيقى]
بض
ه